noch ein foto für den großen moment
china bringt seiner jugend das skifahren
bei für ihn ist es das dritte mal die
kleidung bekommt sie von ihrer schule
früher dauerte es lange meine sachen
anzuziehen aber der lehrer hat mir
gezeigt wie es schneller geht
generalstabsmäßig versucht china eine
wintersportnation zu werden präsident
schien hat 300 millionen chinesen auf
die bretter befohlen skifahren gehört
deshalb oft zum schulunterricht es ist
ein langer marsch zum ruhm für die
anfänge hat das land etwas erfunden
stofftiere als polsterung für den
hintern damit der sturz nicht so wehtut
zu beginn viel mehr skifahren schwer
jetzt aber fällt es mir leicht lounge in
nimmt den schnellzug ins skigebiet den
haben chinas machthaber extra für die
spiele aufgemotzt um die welt zu
beeindrucken
in einer stunde von peking zu den
olympischen sportstätten mit 350 sachen
johnson arbeitet für die pharmaindustrie
verdient gut er ist ein typischer
vertreter einer jungen generation die
sich ausprobieren will
normalerweise spielen chinesen fußball
oder vor allem tischtennis snowboard
gehört mehr zu einer straßenkultur die
ist in china nicht so akzeptiert
ich denke deshalb mag ich
snowboardfahren es gibt mir das gefühl
von freiheit
das olympische skigebiet jean lee ist
umgeben von braunen bergen im schnitt
regnet es hier gerade einmal ein paar
zentimeter im jahr ohne kunstschnee
fährt hier niemand der wird nachts aus
den unzähligen kanonen gesprüht vor
knapp 20 jahren gab es wenige fahrer
jetzt kommen jedes jahr bis zu 450.000
besucher china ist reich geworden immer
mehr menschen können sich den teuren
sport leisten
die läden sind voll mit europäischen
marken jeder wittert das große geschäft
mit den olympischen spielen
[Musik]
wir haben jedes jahr zweistellige
wachstumsraten in jedem skigebiet der
chinesische markt ist bereits für
anfänger der größte markt der welt
lilo weiß wovon er spricht er ist ein
star in germany dem milliardär gehört
eine der größten bäckereiketten schülers
quasi als hobby hat er sich dieses
skigebiet zugelegt in seinem büro
blickte auf seine werke und träumt von
einer gigantischen ski zukunft zur
politik will er nichts sagen nur dass es
um sehr viel geht
das ziel unseres vorsitzenden ist ein
gesundes china aufzubauen und das mit
hilfe von sport die olympischen spiele
brauchen wir dafür präsident dschihad in
den bergen von jean lee die olympischen
stätten inspiziert es geht ihm um viel
mehr als nur um die volksgesundheit er
will der welt chinas überlegenheit
demonstrieren im staatsfernsehen werden
stolz die wettkampfstätten als die
modernsten präsentiert die es jemals gab
einige milliarden us dollar wird das
land wohl investieren
china will sich mit den spielen eine
goldmedaille umhängen supersprung
bei euch sieht das sehr sicher aus
chinas macht elite weiß dass sie am
pranger steht presse den ski lässt die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong
unterdrücken er steckt uiguren ins
arbeitslager mit den spielen will das
angeschlagene image seines landes
aufpolieren
er setzt dabei auf das olympische
komitee und dessen präsidenten den
deutschen thomas bach der ist gerade
frisch wiedergewählt worden und will vom
boykott nichts wissen es ist wohl am
ende ein machtkampf der beiden
weltmächte in den usa haben sich mehrere
politiker bereits für einen boykott
ausgesprochen
us-präsident beiden prüft diese frage
die botschaft an peking alle optionen
liegen auf dem tisch
wir beraten mit unseren verbündeten um
unsere gemeinsame strategie zu bestimmen
aber im moment gibt es keine diskussion
unsere pläne zu diesem zeitpunkt zu
ändern
das wird vom bin gerne hören er ist
einer der vielen tausend offiziellen
helfer die olympia zu einem triumph in
china machen sollen
peking ist die einzige stadt der welt
die sowohl sommer als auch winterspiele
veranstaltet hat eine großartige ehre
er zeigt uns das inoffizielle
wahrzeichen der spiele big air
die sprungschanze für die snowboarder
von hier blickt man auf chinas
stillgelegte stahlindustrie die das land
stark gemacht hat daneben werden neue
hightech zentren gebaut chinas zukunft
internationale firmen sollen hier
investieren
dafür braucht es olympia ein boykott
wäre eine katastrophe
ein boykott der olympischen spiele hätte
immensen wirtschaftlichen schaden für
unser land
wir werden nichts unversucht lassen
damit das nicht passiert
knapp ein jahr vor den olympischen
spielen unternimmt der staat alles um
aus china eine wintersportnation zu
machen
zum boykott wollen sich die menschen
eigentlich nicht äußern
john sheehan den wir im zug getroffen
hatten will einfach sein leben genießen
snowboardfahren als ausdruck der jugend
anders zu sein
darum geht es für ihn und nicht um
politik
wir sollten den olympischen geist nicht
mit der politik vermischen
das problem sind heute die feindlichen
welt anschauen
sport ist dafür da den menschen freude
im leben zu bringen
da spricht er wohl für die meisten
chinesen sie wollen ihren neuen
wohlstand genießen und haben gelernt
sich von der großen politik festzuhalten